so I went to this dinner last night and  I walked into a door that said restroom  it was not a restroom it was a utility  closet that had a drop down and I fell  over I luckily pushed a table away  because my face was about to go into it  and does anyone remember Samantha Jones  and Sex in the City like calling him and  Landing like spread eagle into a vat of  vegetables well this was like that  except for no soft landing and a bat of  vegetables and I'm lying there and I'm  by myself because no one's around it's a  utility closet and then this one nice  guy comes in he's like are you okay and  I was like  I was like I just need a minute oh my  God and then he pulled me up and now I'm  walking around with like a damage  luckily just my right butt cheek is  broken  one of your movies would marry the guy  that found you